foreign
[Music]
ERS with me at spectator offices in
Westminster London today I'm joined by
star of this stage
television and the Silver Screen James
Dreyfus
James thank you so much for joining me
what a lovely intro well I I was a
little bit Starstruck actually as you
you came in into the building because
um not only were you on the television
growing up with gimme gimme gimme was
was something I I I I and The Thin Blue
Line were two shows I watched you know
avidly yeah and um and then I saw you on
the on the in the West End uh doing the
producers
my God yeah so you thought who's this
walloping great fatty coming down the
stairs now exercise here
um well no it's uh it's really a great
pleasure and and um one of the things
we've been exploring in in on this show
is freedom of expression in the Arts but
um for context
um
I I hope you don't mind me saying this
but I think in those shows particularly
gimme gimme gimme
you were or became the face of uh I
guess gay people in the living rooms of
the UK or that's probably not well
articulated but you normalized it I
think or homosexuality for a lot of
people and I don't think it's a
coincidence uh similarly to an America
How Will and Grace by the end of that
series
um or near after 10 years of that show
that thereabouts uh gay marriages legal
across 50 states and in this country
something similar happened only a couple
years after gimme gimme gimme finished
were was gay marriage legalized in 2015.
do you think that that's a fair first do
you think you had that sort of impact on
the culture I think we did uh I think we
did in some ways uh what was what was
very curious about uh give me give me
give me was the fact that it got a real
kicking from the gay press uh which I
always found very very odd because it
was okay it was a silly Scooby-Doo
cartoon type
but and and they were both vital people
but the one thing that he was
absolutely fine about and didn't you
know was very happy about himself was
the fact that he was gay that was
incidental to him being this character
and I think possibly that was the first
time uh that was
um that was seen but that's down to
Jonathan Harvey's writing so uh
initially I I think um you know a lot of
the gay press well who's this sort of
skinny very odd looking guy you know I
think they would have much preferred
um you know a straight good-looking guy
uh to play it because that's what they
used to put on all their magazines you
know they'd put on straight young fit
boys and say How brave they were to be
on the front of a gay publication so
it's sort of quite strange but I agree
with you I think but certainly older
people and certainly young people it
sort of made I always found that these
people used to come up to me and go you
know I didn't really care yeah you know
I I think the media has put a lot of use
to put a lot of but a pressure on people
and say you know it's these dark days we
were coming out of those dark days the
dark days of the 80s and you know
associated with with being pedophiles
and and AIDS and you know they were all
linked together so I think it was the
final sort of bursting thing although
Queer as Folk did also do some brilliant
work as well so um it's sort of
retrospectively looking back on it now I
I couldn't see what you're saying right
okay did you feel like it at a time it
didn't feel like do you feel like I know
that you were doing array of stuff and
and um it's it's certainly unfair to
portray you as a gay actor considering
the scope of your work but did you feel
at the time that you represented
obviously not to the gay press but to
others that you represented a a a a gay
person on the television no I didn't and
I I really didn't because I never wanted
to be
um uh responsible for any anybody else's
I was involved in these over-the-top
silly comedies but I was doing them
because I was working with my comedy
Heroes so I was working with Alexis ale
I was working with Jennifer Saunders I
was working with
um uh Rowan Atkinson and Ben Elton
you know these are all my heroes so it
just so happened I went from silly
comedy to Ott comedy to
Ott comedy and they all happened to and
if you're in an Ott comedy you move
about a lot and your arms about a lot
and you know uh and I mean the character
in Thin Blue Line wasn't gay I I always
in my head
yeah he was in love with Habib but I
always used to think of Frank Spencer
who was you know you couldn't get camper
than Frank Spencer brilliant he was
married to Betty uh but obviously I got
that wrong because everyone said oh
you're that gay policeman even though
that that uh you sort of you were you
worse I think it did
normalized campus even yeah I mean I I I
guess in some ways it did but again
again
um you know at this stage the the gay
press was certainly you know we don't
want I think they were we were also
coming out of you know the John Monument
thing back in the 70s and and the 80s
gay characters were you know very very
obvious and very you know and they were
sort of saying well we don't want this
type of uh comedy before and had
Jonathan Harvey written a comedy which
was sort of naturalistic we wouldn't
have done it like that we only did it
like that because it was a big cartoon
and it had to be big and it had to be
over the top yeah
um well now I mean it's the the gay
presser on your back again
um and uh so uh you've there's there's a
few things happen here so on the uh one
hand uh you you you've taken the support
of people like JK Rowling and you signed
a letter uh supporting her and her
movement for women's rights and um
there's a superb article you wrote for
lesbian and gay news I suppose that's
one gay publication that isn't against
you yes but it's gone so oh really yes
several months ago they couldn't survive
there was too much nefarious activities
going on behind the scenes and
unfortunately they folded but you
haven't heard the last of David Bridal
who was the editor he'll come back with
something else and let's hope so
um so what's the story with Doctor Who
and uh there was an audio book where you
were to yeah you had even recorded I
believe the sorry I'd recorded uh quite
a number of them and uh what happened
and I was playing the master
and what happened was
um I I got a phone call from Graeme
Linehan who I've known for 30 years I I
did my first job with him he he was the
writer before he wrote Father Ted and he
said look
I just want to bring this to your
attention would you sign
um a letter uh a public letter to
Stonewall asking for a respectful debate
because Stonewall had said no debate a
debate between Linehan and stanmore uh
no between between uh women and
um the trans rights movement because
there was a conflict of interest there
was it was you know a lot of a lot of
what they were asking was impinging upon
hard-won writes that women had fought
for years and years and years to achieve
and I thought that was perfectly
reasonable to ask for a respectful
debate
and not just come back with no debate
that's it
so I signed that and then of course
um he sent me a letter saying look how
uh have you seen what's happening with
JK ravling and I and I hadn't so it was
Graham that woke me up to this so of
course I read
I read first off what she'd written and
I read it a couple of times and I
thought this is
this is unbelievable if people are
calling her transphobic because of this
yeah there is nothing transphobic there
nothing and I've also met her before and
I know her uh and I know what she's done
for the gay community in terms of how
much she supported them and how much
she's given financially I was at a table
with her in 2004 when she helped the
Terence against Trust
hmm survive for a good number of years
let's put it like that so I knew that
you so of course I said and I read the
threats written to her which were just
disgusting in every from every possible
angle it was revolting so of course I
thought any decent person would do the
same
little did I know
uh I signed this letter and the next day
I woke up and my mentions were full of
attack from
um a lot not all but a lot of Doctor Who
fans a lot of Television people
um just sort of saying I was I was a
trans transphob no debate I said I was
out dancing with Tran with transsexuals
before you were even born so don't tell
you tell me I grew up with them I have
trans friends you know I know I'm not my
friends no I'm not but back then it was
a real shock and I was like when did
this come about and they said this
company that I was working for big
finish had released a statement saying
we do not support transphobia in any
shape or form
um
uh uh uh and they didn't mention my name
but they said you know we strive to be
inclusive but and then I started
noticing that my name and my photograph
was disappearing
off these audio uh CDs that were coming
through and I called my agent but I said
that's funny it looks like I'm sort of
rubbed out stalinistic yes I mean but I
was puzzled anyway they came back and
said no no it's nothing and I called
again about a month later when the new
one came out and my name had been
removed again and I said look
something's going on can you find out
eventually I get a call saying ah yeah
there is a problem
um it's to do with your signing the
letter
uh from before Rowling and for Stonewall
and I said you know I haven't heard one
thing from them hadn't got an email
hadn't got it but they hadn't noticed
they hadn't said anything to me they
then brought out a collection of all the
people that have played The Master and
it was called masterful and they
informed my agent they would not be
including me
so what it did was compound publicly
the fact that I was transphobic and that
was the reason I was dropped so it did
enormous damage to me and completely
unfounded
um and I I was just astonished they
released it they've never said anything
about it they've never apologized
they've they they literally did it
sneakily behind my back and I thought
this is just outrageous I mean just
outrageous show me some evidence show me
proof but of course they never can
because there isn't any the accusation
and the process is the punishment that's
the punishment where do you think that
energy comes where does your interest
come in on that so the the with JK
Rowling what about it so so boiled your
your blood I tell you because number one
there's a personal thing it was a
personal thing the issue itself but the
issue itself is is here was a woman who
wrote A deeply compassionate essay which
you have to read a couple of times and
you have to and talked about her own
experiences of sexual abuse this is a a
woman who wrote
um the most successful books in the
world penniless with her kids in a cafe
and I think that
um a strong independent woman who has
her own mind and speaks out on an issue
that's very close to her
is being used as a sort of misogynist
football
uh the number of times I I hear I say to
people well have you have you read what
she wrote no I don't need to because you
know I was told she was a transfer you
know very few people have read what
she's actually written yeah
are you I know you're getting you
described getting a lot of online abuse
and then you're also the quiet kind of
eradication of your work but are you
actually meeting people in the industry
who are challenging you on these things
are you actually is there a face-to-face
aspect not once huh
not until I did a job recently where
this highly intelligent very young actor
in his twenties
we had a discussion about he used
certain pronouns and I said well I have
no problem with that I mean you know
you're my friend if you know you asked
me in all sincerity to use them I'd make
an effort I'd I'd screw it up because
just grammatically it's difficult for my
54 year old brain to deal with but of
course I would if you wanted me to
um
but but the point is is that no one has
ever challenged me what I have felt and
Andrew Doyle has said the same thing is
you know if I go I don't go to any
acting functions or anything I haven't
done for 15 years but when you walk you
go to see a show or something you'll see
people so it's like a departing of the
Red Sea some people will go out of their
way to avoid you and on Twitter I'm very
careful about publicly
messaging my friends because I don't
want them to get embroiled in what I'm
embroiled yeah so do you get a sense
that you're there are people who are
thanking you as well maybe for for the
line I get I get a ton of private
messages a day from people in the
industry in from lots of different
artistic points Lots privately saying if
I speak up now
uh I will lose my job my income and I
say listen if you're not ready to speak
out I totally get it because these
people are out to destroy you if you
bump The Narrative and it doesn't matter
what your beliefs are you could say the
mildest thing if you step out of line I
mean the other day
um a major trans supporter
um uh made a mistake with pronouns and
the tras jumped on it yeah I mean
absolutely towards pieces so there's no
middle tras trans radical activist and
that's not saying transsexual uh radical
activist because I don't believe this is
about transsexuals I think I I you know
feel sorry for these transsexuals who
are stuck in the middle of this who are
saying look I know I'm not a real woman
or stroke man and you know they that you
know they're the middle ground and how
they used to be all proud of being trans
because believe it or not yeah why while
back people would say I'm the trans I'm
I'm perfectly proud transsexual I knew
many of them and suddenly they've been
forced to go underground again and
they're caught in the middle of this
Garcia I'm talking about these young
people who know about not only young but
also
Stonewall who've made some terrible
decisions
um egging these young people on that
they're so confused they're so
aggressive they're so angry they're so
confused that I wouldn't be a kid now
for all the tea in the world because I
don't think they've been helped and I
don't think it's all their fault I think
it's I think they've been let a merry
dance absolutely where do you think
Stonewall have gone wrong was there a
time when you you supported them all oh
yeah I supported Stonewall right up to
2050 I supported that we used to do go
do these things at the Albert Hall and
in things once a year called the
equality show where we were promised
equality that's what we wanted we wanted
equal rights so that you what was
equality there
equality was well you know that you
could get married illegally so that you
could have the same legal in in the law
you could have the same right so if you
if you separated you had then that you
could bury your partner and you could
earn the other partners parents couldn't
stop you from going to the funeral which
used to happen
um you know it was a very very sort of
underground and sort of murky business
back then and we just wanted I thought
we were working towards where I would no
longer be called an openly gay actor
which came after every bloody time my
name was mentioned I've done it a little
bit and I miss an interview no no you
haven't you haven't I mean about yes sir
um
um and that was what I was promised 2015
that instead of going we are a gay
lesbian bisexual organization we've got
equality now let's focus on countries
where they throw homosexuals off roofs
and kill them and stone them let's let's
focus on that and help them no they
decided to add the tea which if which is
fine except it's it's thrown everything
off now and Stonewall are actively
hostile towards homosexuals and lesbians
and bisexuals now because if you don't
tow that line you're known as gender
critical and you are I mean Owen Jones
put out a tweet the other day saying you
are hated you are reviled by most of the
community to you this is no no just
generally
and uh I just thought I think this is
him beginning to panic a little bit and
realize that people are waking up so
Stonewall have said and then the the
head of Stonewall Ruth Hunt said
this is not quote but this is the gist
we know we are taking a risk by doing
this and we know that some people won't
like it and won't appreciate it but we
have decided that is a risk worth taking
so they knew the boat was about to be
rocked and ever since 2015 that book has
been rocking and rocking and rocking so
much so that when you only have to ask
Stonewall a question you only have to
ask why is this image allowed why what
why is an image of a man in a trans flag
with his boot on the face of a gay man
in a gay uh thing crunching it into the
ground into the ground and I sent this
copy to one of the directors of
Stonewall and said why why are you
allowing this why aren't you speaking up
nothing nothing it seems very bizarre to
pair LGB with t because LGB is a sexual
preference thing and trans is is a sense
of you're feeling your your gender so
it's it's what happened in 2015 I know
that that's when uh gay marriage was
legalized
um but what well why did what happened
within Stonewall well the Stonewall
introduce the umbrella
and that I think was the basis of all
the problems because the moment you you
say look we put trans lesbians we put
transgaming we put transsexuals we put
transvestites we put drag queens we put
if you're feeling
um non-binary if you're feeling too
Spirit of it you put them all under one
umbrella because if because then if
there's a particular group tras
who are causing trouble and everything
it's very easy then to say you're
anti-trans because it's all under one
umbrella
so it's actually a sort of catch-all
thing and a lot of people are saying
excuse me you've gone from being an
organization that supports homosexuals
lesbians and bisexuals
to now bringing in a whole lot of people
I mean don't tell me
coming out as non-binary is the same as
coming out as gay uh uh it's not people
get kicked out of houses and uh are
abandoned by their families you say
you're non-binary I mean the most you
get is a well okay good for you yeah
that's fine well I think this is linked
to one thing from your lesbian again
news article which I I'd like to read if
that's okay um that I found interesting
I just wanted to understand it better
now we are witnessing an unprecedented
Resurgence of unbelievable homophobia
aimed at young gay guys who dare to
critique the new cue Ideology Now
understanding how it's why it's
homophobic I think is is I'd like to
that understand that better well for on
point one uh this is a personal
preference for people of my generation
don't you might you must remember that
queer was the word uh that we heard when
getting you know your head kicked in and
it was used you know as a extremely
derogatory term now I understand that
you know people say
you know use it now and they say we've
reclaimed it it's well it's fine if you
want to call yourself queer that's
absolutely fine there's no business of
mine at all but please don't say to me
that's what I am please don't refer to
me as being sis
no I'm a guy
a lot of things are being imposed
this is not a fair exchange this is you
will call me this you will do this you
will behave in this way and a lot of
people are comparing to the gay rights
struggle of uh the 80s and the 70s but
this is nonsense the gay rights struggle
did not
impinge
or try and move in on anyone else's set
of Rights
this is happening now in sports in
changing areas in communal areas in
every aspect of a woman's life you only
have to go online and see what people
are saying it's actually nothing to do
with the translation what they're saying
is safeguarding
which is why we had separation of men
and women in the first place
safeguarding for children for that and
that's not to say you know that that
people are saying transsexuals are a
danger they're a pretty no one is saying
that but of course they're saying we're
saying it we're not we're saying there
has to be safeguarding there are women
who have been raped out there have been
domestically abused and the sight or
sound of a a male thing they you know
they do not need culturally speaking
Jewish and Muslim women need separate
spaces the thing this is impinging in a
lot of ways on a lot of people and I
think
there's a sharp divide and and this is
what women uh like Maya Foster to Julie
bindel Allison Bailey
um Kathleen stop all these people are
saying look we spent years getting here
years yeah with a lot of Blood Sweat and
Tears and you're now coming in not even
asking not even having in a decent way
saying let's have a conversation about
this but this onslaught of hate and
think no wonder women are turning around
and saying do you want to know something
I don't want to share my changing room
with you if you're going to stand there
and take a picture of your erection in
the woman's bathroom and then send it to
me you know why would I want to do this
safeguarding is now less important and
that's the point I'm trying to make and
the homophobia is off the scale now it's
I I get more homophobic abuse
um by default uh I am if your same-sex
attracted
because you're generally obsessed my
point is no it's the whole man it's the
smell the way he looks or the way he
tilts his head that's what it is nothing
to do with the genital but it's what it
makes a man a man if you are that way
then you are inherently transphobic well
you can't win can you stop working yeah
yeah once you control the language you
control
everything else that follows so they're
controlling the language but are you
encouraged by the legal developments
that are happening you mentioned Maya
Force data who last year won her case
that her gender critical gender critical
opinions are a protected belief
and uh then this year this summer
Allison Bailey as you mentioned yeah won
her case um against the yeah Gardens
Court Chambers uh because they were
investigating her uh for her gender
critical associations and social media
and she was one of the co-founders of
LGBT Alliance as well as being a
barrister and and Tavistock now being
and this is what really got me is and
into this whole issue is the way
children are being mutilated
um but Tavistock has been told to close
by Spring next year
um does that give you encouragement does
that make you feel like I I think things
are going in the right direction yes in
two ways really number one I always
think sunlight is the best way of
um
of dealing with these things I mean you
could one can [ __ ] and moan and fight
on Twitter as much as you like
um you're not going to win any arguments
that way you're just not the the way
this is going to be solved and um
d-transitioners are a very very
important voice to listen to the kids um
you know who are now
growing up who say listen you know I was
a kid when this happened and and this
has ruined my life this is done
irreversible damage people should really
start paying attention to what D
transitioners have to say and there are
plenty of them online that tell their
stories yeah and and and and I I'm
hoping that the the mainstream media
pulls their finger out and starts
addressing this so in one way
sunlight through these court cases is
happening also in another way I think
that once it gets into court it's almost
like um you know unless you've got an
extremely woke judge sitting there the
judge sort of looks and goes really this
came to this came to court this is this
is just extraordinary well we're seeing
that I think with the court case that's
going on at the moment between LGB
Alliance and mermaids We've got there
we've got there I mean I know the all
the founders of the LGB Alliance I mean
I think they're just a Gog at this it is
the only charity the only one for gay
lesbians and bisexuals there are plenty
for Trans people and also trans people
are welcome to come in they're not
nobody wants to see them not exist
nobody wants them erased this is
hyperbole to get to whip up feeling
against the alliance the alliance is far
from a hate group it is a charity to
help and actually what there's they've
got a very small staff they were asked
the other day well why aren't you doing
more it's just because we're sitting
here having to defend ourselves in this
ridiculous court case yeah but in
another way
more sunlight more people listening more
decisions will be made and I think once
the court cases start coming in from
detransitioners
uh which is certainly going to happen in
the future we're going to see a
bloodbath I mean we're going to see a
bloodbath and if it is reported
correctly people will be alarmed at the
lack of again safeguarding and we're
talking about kids
absolutely absolutely I've got I've got
two friends I know who were gender
dysphorica's children and didn't
transition although were encouraged to
and they
um have both said that had they gone
through of it they would almost
certainly have committed suicide which
which is again the argument we're told
is if they don't do the surgery they'll
commit suicide exactly exactly and
there's there's also this thing about
conversion therapy you know obviously
we're all against conversion therapy of
trying to convert someone from being gay
to being straight I mean that's
horrendous but there's also something
which they say doesn't exist but we have
reams of evidence for it of transiting
the Gale away there's a lot of people
well let's say In America which has a a
far a quite a religious right uh which
they say that they funds the LGBT
Alliance which is of course
load of poppy [ __ ] improvable poppy [ __ ]
uh but of course um there is a
particular woman who works at mermaids
who was caught on camera saying she
trounced her son because
her father the son's father did not want
a gay son
Iran has the I think it's the second
highest population of trans people
because that is less embarrassing or a
less unacceptable than having a gay son
so homosexuality is there is still the
lowest on the list now what is that if
that's not conversion therapy what would
you call it yeah I'd call it another
form of conversion therapy and agree
it's like horrendous homophobia and
horrendous homophobia but now it's sort
of allowable homophobia it's sort of if
you say hang on a second something's not
right here
every word Under the Sun is thrown at
you you know well you you talked about
all those those words in the abuse in
that uh article which there's another
point in the article I'd like to bring
up because I thought it was interesting
and it's back to the creative Industries
is we we have actresses playwrights
composers agents even calling for
boycotts of others Works based on
hysteria and falsehoods yeah so what it
you've already described what's happened
with Doctor Who um but what what's the
atmosphere are you you're still working
you haven't been completely ostracized
from on the business what's the
atmosphere what's what's going on behind
closed doors well
um for let's take an example yeah uh
let's start with an example Terry Terry
Gilliam
member of the original founding members
of Monty Python was going to bring
Steven sometimes into the woods to the
old Rick
and suddenly the uh the people who
worked at the Old Vic some of the young
people said they weren't happy having
Terry Gilliam bring his work to the Old
Vic because in the past Terry Gilliam
had said oh well if we're talking about
talk about identifying I identify as a
one-legged black lesbian which is the
type of thing that someone from Monty
Python would say right that's not a joke
no so the kid said we are not having
this
uh uh and actually influenced policy at
the Old Vic so that the old Victor said
we are we unfortunately due to what uh
Terry gilliam's remarks we shall not be
taking it here hallelujah the theater
Royal bath took it on so it is happening
but we're talking about now the the the
tail wagging the dog we've got this is
happening in universities it's happening
everywhere everywhere at the moment that
some young people say I'm offended and
people are capitulating immediately
instead what they should be doing is
being the adults in the room and they'd
and say if you don't like it then leave
be quiet you're paid to do that
particular job just sit down and do it
because there are plenty of other people
who will come and do it for you this is
and this is happening in students I you
know canceling this whole Council
culture does exist I hate to break into
you but throwing professors out and
intimidating them and and masking up and
standing there you know calling
themselves anti-fascists I've never seen
a bigger bunch of fascists in my life
anti-facets don't behave like that no
and they're currently they cover
themselves it's if you really believe in
yourself show yourself yeah I agree yeah
um the the uh there's a surprising lack
of adults in the room and and I've seen
this in the music industry it was last
week uh or
um time from this conversation that
Spitfire audio the co-founder of
Spitfire audio Christian Henson uh um
was made to take a break from his job
because he's declared his support for
Graeme Linehan and JK Rowling and
um a concern for uh autistic children
specifically and and about about the
trans stuff and his from his own company
the CEO has made him take take a break
you think one on earth they're doing and
now it's likely I I think that there'll
be a bigger pushback against that
company because people are fed up with
the canceling stuff and so at certain
point and maybe that's what's going to
take it because for a while I thought it
might take a critical match like we
might need a critical mass of people
brave enough like yourself to stand up
to the lunacy and but and they're slowly
happening more and more but actually
it's it's the people going you know what
if you're gonna if you're going to treat
people like that to having a different
opinion from you frankly an opinion
based in empathy and love and serious
concern for children then maybe we're
not going to work for you so it's
canceling the council culture which I do
think it exists and you you've
experienced it but there's a cancer
culture now people who are doing the
counseling absolutely well it's
interesting you say that because uh I
saw on the day that uh again they acted
the CEO acted in the most cowardly awful
way uh by knifing him in the back
publicly and saying Christian needs to
go and sort himself out uh there was
enormous support for Christian Henson we
actually got I stand with Christian
Henson trending
um I I think more and more people are
saying but what does he say what did he
say and of course people have receipts
and they said this is what he said and
people go
you're telling me that's that's the
reason why you only have to I mean as
you explained to me yourself uh you did
one tweet and and look what happened
um but it more and more and more I mean
when we were talking about uh Sports
um you know you had Martina
saying very loudly and very proud of you
and no yes and then you have Sharon
Davis saying no and then suddenly on one
day all these Olympians came out
together and said no so they're there
they're waiting for this thing to happen
and I think the more this
um this sort of canceling for just it's
almost like you have to walk a straight
line and even if you wobble off that
line even slightly that's enough that is
enough and I think people will slowly
begin to go this is just ridiculous you
what you are doing are ruining people's
lives you are ruining their ability to
make a living you are you're actually
and even if they and the worst thing to
do and I know you were advised to do
this but the worst thing you can do is
apologize and explain the worst thing
because an apology is well is never
enough they will drag you through the
mud as I think I've said
on other occasions I mean you have to
self-flagellate for weeks and weeks and
weeks and even then you're never
forgiven yeah so so I think of course
normal decent people are going to be
looking at this and going there's
something not right here but this is
still early days I mean even five years
there's no not long it's it's still a
Grassroots sort of
thing but I I hope people are waking up
you can see evidence every day of people
waking up yeah and you mentioned Owen
Jones earlier and it seems that there
are some people the activists on on the
other side who are really digging in
their heels on the issue and perhaps
that's because they've put themselves in
a position that they can't be wrong yeah
and and so it's it's there's there's no
way getting out of it I mean there's no
way I mean in this on this particular
issue you you have to
choose which Hill you're going to die on
there's no [ __ ] footing around on this
you cannot be in the middle because in
the Middle Ground doesn't exist anymore
they won't allow the middle ground we
try to have the middle ground five years
ago when we said look can we debate this
yeah can we at least sit around the
table and say look these are the areas
of conflict let's try and sort out
what's going on but trouble is there's
this there is this thing still which is
you know when a woman talks that they're
called shrill you know when a man talks
you know he's he's being firm when a
woman talks shrill and I still believe
this is sort of deep rooted misogyny and
the fact that they thought no why should
we listen to a bunch of screaming women
why should we why should we do that we
are the charity that makes decisions
about this
shut up and put up you old dinosaurs you
know that's basically what was done now
I'm sorry but that is rather like
hurling a rock into a hornet's nest
laughing and running away what do you
think they're gonna do they're gonna
come out and say we're not having that
and this is where we are now yeah and is
it something you're going to continue
fighting are you glad to be in this
Audrey do you have any regrets but by
putting your name on your neck on the
line I have no regrets at all I that I
mean if I was not on social media and
not aware of this I would have spoken up
and said something uh you know being
canceled or whatever is just part and
parcel of it um other people have had
much worse than me
um it's part and past of it you can't
dip your toe into this you know it's
it's it's like having a but you either
get in the bath and you fight it or
don't bother putting your toe in because
once you even say the word you're in it
yeah yeah so
um but this is the first it's a bigger
fight than just this it's it's it's sort
of now it's not right versus left it's
it's the woke versus the non-work to use
those words but it's uh you know that's
where we are yeah but uh there there's
uh despite the what you've gone through
you are filming again it was yes and how
was that uh it was actually a lot of fun
it was it was amazing I sort of
Forgotten what I had to ask on the first
day so it was my character do that you
know and she's like just make it up so I
so I did so it was a lot of fun but you
know that doesn't mean I'm suddenly
uncanceled it just means that there was
um you know someone sensible enough to
go you know well I've I've read what
he's written I don't delete well that's
very encouraging then so there are
aspects of the film industry that aren't
there are adults still in the room there
are people in there you know what they
definitely are they definitely are and
also it's it's a it's a it's a good
thing that it's it was film because you
don't have to announce you're doing it
if I suddenly just play I'm wondering
whether things might be slightly
different because you know your
publicity wise you they say well he's
going to be in this in four weeks that
gives a lot of them time to say let's go
and uh stand there with whistles and you
know and make our disapproval known so I
don't know so actually it's people are
it's the it's the attention they don't
like it's the negative press that that
it's not really about your beliefs it's
more about them not wanting that sort of
public it's a rather like Gremlin and
you know having the Father Ted musical
ready to go and not being supported in
it so you know they say well basically
you you take your name off we'll do it
it's outrageous and it is outrageous and
this is other artists the same as you
get bloody created yeah it's it is it's
extraordinary so where it used to be all
all publicity is good publicity now it's
no news as good news absolutely how can
we watch this film you you've uh you've
you've met you've is it we don't know
what the title is yet there's still to
be discussed so no I don't know
um I will let you know behind the scenes
and then you can mention it on on your
website but by the way come on watch
this well James thank you so much for
your time and for sharing and um uh it's
been very enlightening and I'm sure uh
viewers and listeners will have found it
fascinating thank you I've had a
wonderful chat with you so thanks very
much I appreciate it
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]